starting off this hours Daniel in
Cincinnati hey Daniel how are you hey
Dave are you doing better than I deserve
what's up I just want to thank you for
all of you do your shows already begun
to change my life and my family as well
so I'm very thankful for you thank you
how can I help today kind of a maybe a
unique situation I've heard you speak on
it in the past before but I wanted some
specific clarity I guess and so if I do
so in January of this year and I'd
already kind of had baby step one and
baby step three completed but I skip
baby step two and also like I'm supposed
to I'd have been so I've been kind of
working on that and working on that with
my wife we've been married for about a
little over a year and a big question
for you is more of some guidance and
maybe just kind of a how to do this for
the right legis but it's it's kind of a
family thing so my wife has some student
loan debt totaling 33,000 at the
beginning of the year and before this
was before we year we were together
dating or married but to my
understanding her and her father had he
had a treatment I guess but if she were
to go to a Christian in front of a
college that he would pay for the
college I'm in full the problem having
now is kind of after once we started
having talks of marriage and stuff her
parents were to talk to us about this
and come to an understanding on it but
apparently her mom wasn't really in the
loop on that conversation and on that
idea so now we're at the point where
we're having conflicting ideals when it
comes to her dad versus her mom versus
you know my wife and what we should do
about these two mister a long day whose
name is the student loan debt in so it's
definitely in her name but I think it's
also our mom's and I think it's I think
it's cosign
I'm not certain that's not about a
Parent PLUS loan than it is a
straight-up student loan yeah there's
there's multiple there was different
laws so there was a yeah so what is your
household income household income was
aiming to be seventy thousand this year
I make forty my wife was making thirty
Sharon she just lost her job about ten
days ago and she's researching
optimistic about that that she'll
probably find something similar in a
couple weeks
sure okay good and what other debt do
you have I'm so my car loan
unfortunately about a brand-new car a
year ago before I found yet that's the
debt we're working on paying off right
away right now where I'm at eleven
thousand right now I bought it for
eighteen you have any other debt other
than your car loan of eleven thousand
and thirty three thousand dollars of
student loan debt no other day okay good
and how much is in your emergency fund
where you skip the step we have a
thousand in there right now okay pay off
your car today okay and then pay off
your student loans mm-hmm as fast as you
can so my wife is a little uneasy about
about doing uh I tried to get her to
knock down to get her degree I'm
knocking our savings down to the South
I'm like I've heard you say before but
she's a little uneasy I guess about that
especially was well there's AMA says
you've been talking about what instead
of why okay no no you guys can get you
make seventy thousand dollars a year you
can get out of this debt but you can't
you can't if you work your plan because
you've helped no one get out of debt and
we've helped millions so I mean you have
to decide who you what you're gonna do
here yeah so it's up to you guys you can
live your life you're adults you're
allowed to do whatever you want to do
but the way we do things when someone
calls on this show is with as much love
as I possibly can
III want good things for you and my 30
years of helping millions of people what
what would I do if I woke up in your
shoes one year married with forty four
thousand dollars in debt and eleven
thousand dollars in the bank making
seventy thousand dollars a year
well I would work the baby steps and the
reason they're numbered is so that you
do fairly easy stuff here so you know
now can you talk her into it I don't
know I don't know maybe she wants to
work her plan she can work her and if
she wants but I think the two of you
need to sit down and talk about okay
what is our goal if our goal is
financial peace some money in the bank
building wealth and no debt what is the
shortest fastest most efficient way
least painful way to get to that goal
and most probability of getting to that
goal it would be to take your you know
your savings down to a thousand dollars
and pay off your car today
get them a really tight budget and
attack with a vengeance those student
loans because her parents aren't going
to pay them because her mother's in
charge and her mother you know is not
concerned so enough for her husband to
keep his word her daddy is a wimp he's
not going to keep his word and I given
my daughter my word we would be keeping
my word at my house but her daddy's a
wimp you're gonna pay the student loans
mommy's in charge so just get over it
and move on
you don't get to control their house and
they're not gonna pay the bill and the
bill is in your wife's name so you're
gonna pay the bill that's what's gonna
happen and I really wouldn't argue with
them anymore there's no point in arguing
just step back and love them where they
are and it's just how they run their
house and that's cool and then you guys
have to decide how you're gonna run your
house what are we gonna do here are we
gonna just you know wander along and
stay in debt or are we gonna attack this
with a vengeance and a proven plan and
that's what you've got to do so hold on
I'm gonna send you a copy of the book
the Total Money Makeover I might suggest
you just sit down your wife and sehun
won't you read this this is why I'm so
excited and then let's talk about it
before you just reach over and pay off
the car I'm not suggesting you push your
wife around emotionally I'm saying you
explain to her why this is important and
why it works and why we're doing this
and you know a total my makeover book
will help you walk through
that process hey thanks for the call
open phones out here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five what a
sad situation can you imagine how they
make that daughter feel so your parents
that have teens that are getting ready
to go off to college don't make any
deals around student loans don't take
out any student loans why you can't go
to that student loan it's federal law
that's what people think isn't it now
let me tell you you pick a school that
is an in-state school and you study a
degree that is usable and you work while
you're in school not flopping whoppers
at minimum wage but you know dog sitting
babysitting cleaning toilets mowing
grass you can make twenty dollars an
hour doing those things most of us
worked when we were in school it's not
child abuse so send the little princess
to work but earnest school you can
afford and then you don't end up
breaking your promises because you're a
wimp this is the Dave Ramsey show